the beaches and deep blue Caribbean Sea
of Cancun Mexico could have come right
out of a travel brochure Cancun lies on
the tip of Mexico's Yucatan Peninsula to
the holidaymakers Cancun is a tropical
paradise of sun sand and surf to Mexico
it's a moneymaker tourism is the
country's third largest source of
foreign currency Cancun is becoming a
high maintenance location the sand has
to be artificially replaced continuously
the steadily rising seas are washing it
away almost as fast as it can be
restocked the tourism industry is busily
ignoring climate change and its
potential effects as one resort hotel
after the other goes up all along the
Mayan coast immediately affected other
mangrove swamps in Puerto Morelos south
of Cancun many of these swamps are being
drained to build more hotels biologists
Jimena Lopez is an expert on the issue
Carlos with or without permission from
our environmental authority lots of
hotels have been built inside the
mangrove swamp zones the hotel we see
here for example was constructed in what
had been a very well preserved own of
mangrove swamps a glance out of the
window plainly shows that environmental
protection counts for little when it
comes to investment in the tourist
industry
miss Lopez knows the extent of the
damage better than almost anyone every
month she joins a scientist from the
office for nature reserves for an aerial
survey of the coastline the Mexican
federal government is at least
documenting the rapidly accelerating
destruction of the mangroves
the plane curves out over Cancun and
then via South the computer times the
camera to take a continuous strip of
photos of the ground beneath the flight
path
the aerial photos tell a familiar story
hotels along the coast with dying
mangroves right behind them
the consequences of corruption and
haphazardly enforced laws are easy to
see from the air
another half-hour flight down the coast
is the CM con biosphere reserve the
mangrove served to protect the mainland
behind them they form part of a uniquely
adapted ecosystem a natural buffer zone
between sea and land
these last untouched areas have also
come under threat from real-estate
speculation and corruption aerial
surveys are expensive and their
evaluation time-consuming so with the
help of the German scientific society
for Aeronautics the Mexican government
has been increasingly turning to
satellite remote sensing we have the
ability to analyze isolated ecosystems
right now for instance we're conducting
a national inventory of the mangrove
stands with the mangroves there various
issues that have turned critical among
them of course is tourism especially
along the Mayan coast Quintana Roo is an
example most are familiar with Cancun
but shrimp farming is another big
problem in many parts of Mexico to
produce shrimp on a mass scale
unfortunately they also have to clear
mangrove swamps on a mass scale
comparing the satellite data with the
aerial photos provides a preliminary
evaluation the new method has already
revealed some clear trends the mangrove
swamps are shown in green the built-up
areas in gray while the environmental
damage is colored red here we see some
changes in the Mayan coast zone analyze
these changes by comparing old aerial
photos from 1970 with current satellite
data from 2008 the two results are then
collated and this some card comes out
which reveals the changes over time that
almost dd4 in little with each site site
it's about a three-hour flight from
Cancun to Mexico City
estimates of the population of Mexico
City range from 20 to 30 million the
numbers vary widely depending partly on
which boroughs are included the
elevation of the city is easier to pin
down 2,200 meters for the high valleys
floor Mexico City is the country's
undisputed political economic and
cultural hub
the cityscape is a mixed bag of modern
and traditional
Miguel Ventura a native of Puerto Rico
has been living in this megalopolis for
30 years now hay muchas partes you like
there are many parts of the city I don't
even know it's extremely big but I like
that there's something about the spirit
this chaos that I like
Miguel Ventura is an artist the
goethe-institut has invited him to
contribute a project for the 200th
anniversary of Latin American
independence
his studio is still lined with works
from the last exhibition works that
contemplated fascism from a critical
perspective I look at Jordan Perseus
indeed something I began to feel after
the September 11th attacks is this
machiavellian cells very repressive
force right off it makes me think of
fascism with these invasions of Iraq and
Afghanistan these wars based on lies
this too is a combination of the forces
of repression and the forces of
capitalism
this the the force of historical forces
and capitals Ventura uses manipulated
symbols and music from the Third Reich
but of what concern is Germany's dark
past
to him a Latin American important but I
mean an animus on I think it's become
very important for me these past few
years
to recognize the continuity between the
time of the Second World War the Nazis
and now I realize that the history of
Germany was no isolated phenomenon in
our culture and society rather it came
out of the capitalism we live with and
it can repeat itself they don't have to
use the swastika we can use the
coca-cola symbol or whatever I think
these are very dangerous town because
they see some theme of peligro source
words that grate on the ear north of the
border often resonate in hearts and
minds south of it the video the artist
is making for the Goethe Institute's
independence project runs in much the
same vein
it's called Mexican War fair
a part of the projects concept is to
encourage an exchange between Latin
America and Germany
Miguel Ventura gets together with German
artist Bjorn MELAS who also works with
video he's just spent several weeks in
Mexico now Ellis is preparing the shoot
for his own project during his time in
Mexico one thing in particular caught
his attention everyone seemed to be
carrying arms the recent drugs war is
one example his clothes are his way of
expressing his feelings about what he
sees I call this one it's a response to
what people in this country have been
experiencing since about 1994 there's
been an extreme militarization on all
sides when you come here from abroad
it's blatantly obvious I was here in
1992 and didn't see any of this yet it's
a very tangible change in the civilian
society people have almost gotten used
to seeing bulletproof vests and big
automatic rifles all around them in the
streets that in itself is disturbing and
this is my reaction to it
our journey continues east towards
puebla
historically speaking Puebla is an
exception to the rule among Mexican
cities it was founded by the Spanish
there was no indigenous settlement on
the site when the conquistadors arrived
the colonial architecture in the old
town bears witness to its origins
whoo a blur has a reputation as
conservative and arch Catholic many of
the church's art treasures are
concentrated here one is the Chapel of
the Rosary in the Church of Santo
Domingo a total of 56 kilograms of gold
leaf was applied to the inside of the
chapel it was built by indigenous people
from nearby Cholula and black slaves
from what is now bellies it takes
imagination and a sharp eye and above
all the will to find traces of pueblos
Native American heritage add to that the
energy and creativity needed to keep it
alive
his Kintla tisket lopaka was born in
puebla he is one of the city's very few
professional Aztec dancers he dedicates
himself to preserving the pre-columbian
culture handed down by his ancestors the
hand crafts are only one aspect of that
culture
he and his wife have a small workshop
jammed full of pieces and tools
workshops like this preserved traditions
that have been handed down from
generation to generation for centuries
just like the Aztec dance rituals under
the milk industry day you know there are
lines of traditions reaching back to
1531 1731 that's to say these dances
were preserved in a few refugees after
the arrival of the spanish some of the
Franciscan Dominican and Augustinian
priests allowed the people to keep
practicing their dance rituals set to
the mandolin over time they allowed them
to go back to playing drums wait what's
conscious and chiponis
step honestly who's got a colles etc
every Friday with a blow on his conch
his Kim please starts rehearsals with
his dancers outside whenever they can
his group is also attracting more and
more non Mexicans who want to get a feel
for the native rhythms and traditional
steps many people run away from their
traditions their origins their idea of
being beautiful has to have blue eyes
and white skin and then when they see
skin this color they say oh India the
odd thing about it is that they have
skin the same colour and call us India's
I think they've lost their sense of
identity but then everyone has their own
criteria on Sunday morning they prepare
for their upcoming public performance
they made the costumes and instruments
themselves with painstaking attention to
detail this revival of tradition is not
just a show it's the performance of a
ritual material Osito mythos Mak art is
oh me or - and tales or energy the two
integers and it's a matter of seeking
the equilibrium of these two energies
this equilibrium is manifest in for
instance the Sun and the moon or day and
night or man and woman was a matter of
establishing this equilibrium a side
from a skin please own relatives
most of the dancers are students in
recent years Mexicans especially the
younger generation have begun to
rediscover their indigenous cultural
roots
the Aztec dance is not done for personal
enjoyment it's a ritual performed as a
sacrifice an offering in return for what
life gives us it's an offering to the
earth or slightly to the wind or I hate
console to water or absol and fire and
it's an offering to the four cardinal
directions east west north and south
it's an offering to the Sun and everyone
in the community they set off for the
dance arena past an ancient pyramid the
largest in Mexico perched on top is a
Catholic Church
every step has a particular meaning and
refers to certain godheads
or to one of the four cardinal
directions like almost all the Latin
American countries Mexico is a melting
pot of immigrants from many parts of the
world including Germans some came as
refugees others in search of a new life
in tip aztlán in the state of Morelos a
sign advertises a beer garden inside is
a man named Jackie mo helped Germany was
too crowded for his taste I was looking
for another lifestyle but I never
thought I'd end up going to Mexico I
came through South America in the US and
somehow got stuck in Mexico I found a
nice spot and before I knew it I'd put
down roots
blitzie hats we would say I learned
baking much earlier I was a baker in
Germany when you get to 16 if you aren't
the best in school you have to do
something I hadn't baked any bread for
20 years and then I started here and
thought I'd do it right I'll make a
sourdough with right with this we didn't
open so it was very hard to find organic
rye flour here I don't think there are
more than two or three places in all
Mexico that grow the stuff
if you can't make the grades you make
the food and drink goes an old Bavarian
saying Giacomo takes life with a touch
of humor his beer garden is actually
doing quite nicely on the weekends
patrons come from Mexico City in droves
for a taste of his exotic German bread
and beer on tap can he serve as an
example for other emigrants I was fond
reverses immigrants that's a German way
of thinking to say you emigrate but I
didn't really because I never was a real
German right from the start I just never
understood the system with all those
rules it's also how do you say it in
German in Spanish you say artificial'
you have to go by the book and that
never really worked for me only 14 years
no elsewhere things somehow worked
better for Jackie mo and he fulfilled
his Latin American Dream it's a bond
where then I started building houses
I always did enjoy that even in Germany
but you just can't do it then you have
to have studied for it to work out but
here if you can do the job then you can
do it that's how it is here here he did
the job and did it very well so we
thought we'd build ourselves a house
each bro but I needed 160 meters of
bookshelves and that's how we came up
with this thing without plans it was a
house out of the oven like a cake this
wood is will we get back in this house
this in deviant corner what
Wednesday is market day in tepoztlán a
rich variety of merchandise is on offer
dried grasshoppers and nothing out of
the ordinary to giacomo immunity toxic
on me now you know he feels no
homesickness for his Bavarian birthplace
Giacomo seems to thrive here but many of
the native Mexicans feel compelled to
migrate to the United States
the last stop on our journey through
Latin America is tuwana in the north of
Mexico
for most illegal migrants to the US the
road leads through the desert it can be
a dangerous one more than a few on
average about one a day lose their lives
trying to reach what to them is a
promised land
early morning at the busiest border
crossing on earth San Ysidro the
Mexicans heading north here are mostly
legal migrants with jobs in San Diego or
Los Angeles but they still have to wait
in their cars for 2 hours or more
the Mexicans call the border simply
Lenina the line
oh no Meah reversed are you I'm telling
you
so they do
mixed in with the Mexicans waiting to
cross are many Americans returning from
a trip to Tijuana some go for a cheap
holiday or shopping spree others go in
search of medical care more and more
Americans are going south of the border
for health care even if they're insured
at home I have insurance but I'm only
covered up to $1,500 but if the whole
family goes to have their teeth cleaned
it can use all that money up it's
impossible so we go to the dentist in
Tijuana and they aren't the only ones so
many of my patients are Americans and
are then the majority of Mexican
Americans they come here Lee
confidential care first of all because
of the quality and secondly because of
the language that's important of the
dentists and also definitely for
economic reasons it's much cheaper for
them
on Sunday morning dr. Besser real takes
a trip with her family her daughter
Jessica has come to visit she's studying
acting in Hollywood life in Tijuana
seems good these days better than it
once was at any rate I like to see I
like living never see I like the sunsets
and I'm fascinated by all the people
from all over it's multicultural and I
like that Latin America ends here at the
US border in name only
in reality Latin Americans live
throughout the US and Canada as well but
the fence stands here a high-tech
fortification dividing a continent it
even attracts tourists keynoter Mina the
people of this region know that Latin
America doesn't end here it goes on
Mexicans their Central American brothers
and Latinos of many countries on the
American side as well there are the
cultural centers the restaurants and the
workers multitudes of people many of the
border guards here are Mexican descent
so in reality Latin America doesn't end
here but some place in Canada Latin
America may in fact reach all the way to
Berlin but our journey from Tierra del
Fuego to Tijuana ends here